Well, let's start off with the question that's been bothering me.
I can't figure out what your name means.
I'm trying to look it up on the Internet, I can't find it.
What does Mohombi mean?
Do you know why you can't find it?
Because I'm probably, I think I'm the second person...
...in the world? With the name? Really?
Yeah.
So does it have a specific meaning?
It does have a specific meaning in two languages.
In one of them Mohombi Nzasi, that's my first and my second name, means "lightning and thunder."
And so Mohombi means "lightning" in one language...
...and in another language it means "chief."
Like the chief of a tribe.
What are the two languages?
Kikongo and Swahili.
Okay, and the thunder part, what does that mean in the other language?
One of them means "chief," what does the other mean?
Lightning.
Lightning and thunder, Mohombi Nzasi.
Wow, that's really cool.
Who's the first person named Mohombi?
The second person.
You're the second?
No, the second person is actually one of my nephews.
Oh!
Yeah.
Wow!
So that's the good impression I had on my sister.
I guess so!
And so you have 16 brothers and sisters, right?
Yes, we are, in total, 15.
Counting you, 15.
How many nephews and nieces do you have?
Oh, 25.
So, wow!
Crazy for Christmas, you know.
Very expensive.
Yeah, you have to have a pretty big turkey to feed 40 people.
That's right!
Wow!